[Music]
the City of Seattle has a plan to combat
homelessness but critics say it could
come at a cost to actual jobs and one of
the city's largest private employers is
fighting back correspondent Dan Springer
reports from Washington tonight on
whether attacks to clean up the city
could actually clean out job growth the
City of Seattle with its booming tech
industry is poised to lower the boom on
its largest job creators the council is
considering ahead tax of 26 cents for
every hour worked in the city on
companies that grossed 20 million
dollars a year and some businesses will
die or leave Seattle because of this the
tax will raise 75 million dollars from
around 600 companies among them home
Street Bank which has 700 employees in
Seattle but don't land just across the
city line and you start creating a
scenario where it's much more attractive
to house employees outside the city and
that is bad for the city it's bad for
jobs it's bad for the city economy the
tax revenue would be used to build
homeless shelters tiny house villages
and affordable apartments despite
spending on homelessness that is
ballooned to two hundred million dollars
a year the number of those on the
streets or in cars has grown twenty
percent in two years to nearly four
thousand housing and homelessness is
absolutely a regional crisis but we have
to act with urgency right here in
Seattle to get folks inside this creates
almost around 2000 deeply affordable
homes by far the biggest impact will be
felt by Amazon it's looking at an annual
tax of five hundred and forty dollars on
each of its 40,000 employees the online
retailer will pay twenty one point six
million dollars more a year even though
it's spending ten million dollars to
build a homeless shelter in one of its
many new office towers and at the same
time Amazon is looking for a second
headquarters what Amazon is doing is
keeping their options open they're
saying they're gonna set up a
headquarters in another city and then
they can transfer work from Seattle to
other places as needed and it's just a
basic business decision after months of
being silent Amazon has finally fired a
warning shot confirming that it is put
on hold plans to build
office tower in this block and it's
considering subleasing a different
building it owns if the city goes ahead
and passes this ed tax it would be a lot
7,000 jobs not creative Shannon all
right Dan Springer thank you very much
from Seattle